[Musik]
herzlich willkommen am 12 mai vor genau
100 jahren wurde er geboren der deutsche
künstler mit hut und anglerweste der
mann der fett und filz zur kunst machte
der 7000 bäume pflanzte und einen toten
hasen bilder erklärt was wollte diese
umstrittene joseph beuys was haben sie
eine aktion ausgelöst und was kann kunst
heute noch bewirken
darüber rede ich jetzt mit philip
ursprung professor für kunst und
architekturgeschichte an der eth zürich
und autor einer soeben erschienenen
monografie zu joseph beuys herzlich
willkommen herr ursprung danke ja was
ist denn aus ihrer sicht das wichtigste
erbe von joseph beuys was verdanken wir
diesen künstler mit hut er hat die kunst
aus der beschäftigung mit sich selbst
befreit er hat sie vom vom rand ins
zentrum der gesellschaft geführt und er
hat versucht sie zu demokratisieren zu
zeigen dass die kunst nicht für einige
wenige da ist und dann für eigentlich
alle zur verfügung steht
oder hat sogar gesagt jeder mensch ist
ein künstler sein berühmter satz von
beuys ja er hat damit gesagt jeder hat
das potential kreativ schöpferisch zu
sein und jeder hat auch die möglichkeit
so zu leben also aber sie selbst
aufträge geben würde freiheit die die
kunst genießt hat er versucht eigentlich
auf die ganze gesellschaft auszuweiten
also er hat kunst zum thema gemacht
nicht nur für die kunst wird sondern für
eine breite öffentlichkeit und hat auch
die politische relevanz von kunst betont
ja für ihn ist kunst wenn sie aus dieser
selbstbeschäftigung heraus geführt wird
auch ein katalysator wo die
verschiedensten kräfte und möglichkeiten
hindurch gehen und vielleicht auch
verstärkt
dazu gehört ganz stark auch die politik
gehört auch gezeigt wie künstlerisch
politik transformiert werden kann nennt
das die die soziale plastik oder soziale
skulptur als ob alle zusammen gemeinsam
die politik mit formen mitgestalten
können darüber werden wir noch reden
aber interessant an der figur boys ist
ja dass er nicht nur künstler ist
sondern man hat oft den eindruck er
selbst ist irgendwie auch einer seiner
kunstwerke für vielleicht das wichtigste
sogar er hat sich fast von anfang an
verstanden wie wichtig die
personalisierung der kunst ist das dass
diese kunst auch im auto ein stück weit
verkörpert ist dass er dass er ein
schauspieler sein kann dass er auch ein
lehrer ist eine identifikationsfigur und
hat sich dann wenn ich sehr früh dieses
outfit gegeben
das sind sofort wieder erkennbar macht
den hut die die angler weste die jeans
ist eine zusammenstellung von
verschiedenen attributen die sich nicht
ganz klar auf etwas reduzieren lassen
aber die die sicher etwas anders sind
als zum beispiel der anzug mit krawatte
oder die arbeitskluft dass der hut immer
kann das verschiedenste arten deuten
für mich ist es ein stück weit ein
emblem für die zwanzigerjahre kann
einfach nicht anders als als charlie
chaplin mit dem trump dahin sehen die
beste ist das handwerkszeug jemand der
immer ein paar werkzeuge ein paar
bleistift er ein paar zahlen zur
verfügung hat und die jeans das ist die
arbeitslose es ist interessant es ist
wenn man kann über diese dinge viel
spekulieren also der hut ist auch aus
filz ein material das über das wir noch
reden werden dass bei ihm eine wichtige
rolle spielt ebenso wie fett
sie aber haben in ihrer biografie oder
beuys monografie muss man sagen einen
anderen zugang gewährt dann nicht über
die person primär sondern über 1
werke und station warum denn es ist
extrem gut erforscht und beschrieben es
gibt eine fülle von ausgezeichneten
büchern und studien katalogen über ihn
und lange zeit des baus kann man sich
nur durch besser erklären also man muss
das werk immanent betrachten
dann gab es eine phase wo es bei ist
kann man nur durch die ideologie
erklären zum beispiel rudolf steiner und
ich habe versucht auch jetzt im hinblick
auf die etwas größere zeitliche distanz
einen anderen zugang zu finden und mich
fast wie ein tourist in einer
ausstellung oder landschaft zu bewegen
wo ich dann 24 für mich besonders
faszinierende werke besucher und mit den
leserinnen und leser innen quasi
gemeinsam da hingehe als ob ich sie zum
ersten mal anschauen würde
das ist natürlich nicht der fall aber
sie schreiben im buch das sie lange zeit
einen bogen gemacht haben
warum ja ich bin kunsthistoriker und bin
natürlich teil einer
forschungslandschaft dass es ist so viel
interpretiert worden zu beuys erwarte
ich umziehen und von interpreten dass
ich dass ich das gefühl hatte wo immer
ich mich hin bewege ich trete in einen
fettnapf und trete jemandem zu nahe der
schon mal herausgefunden hat und die
diese diese fixierung auf bestimmte
interpretation bestimmte schulen die hat
mich stück weit auch abgeschreckt ich
war angezogen natürlich vom werk aber
zugleich war ich abgeschreckt von der
von der rezeptionsgeschichte und von dem
teilweise auch recht verbitterten
anspruch die richtigen schlüssel zu
haben naja und sehr polarisiert auch die
ganze rezeption also eigentlich
verehrung auf der einen seite
verteufelung auf der anderen seite was
ist dann bei ihm passiert während des 2
haben sie irgendwie neue aspekte kennen
gelernt was würden sie sagen ist so der
augenöffner gewesen der große ja ich bin
ja ich habe hier länger ich mich damit
befasst habe und auch nachdem ich
bestimmte werke bieter oder auch neu
gesehen habe hat sich das bild von beuys
sehr stark noch vergrößert und
differenziert was ich habe ich habe zb
den politischen aspekt neu sehen lernen
und ich habe vor allem auch neu gesehen
wie die bildhauerische die formale die
atmosphärische qualität der werke mich
beeindruckt hat etwas was ich wenn ich
es zu stark vielleicht über bücher
angeguckt habe aus den augen verloren
haben und sie brauchen ein appell wieder
mal hin zu gehen
ein paar dieser ausstellungen sind ja
inzwischen fast ein bisschen angestaubt
ist etwas patina auch dort wieder mal
hin zu gehen und zu schauen wie das
funktioniert und wie das räumlich
funktioniert und die die begegnung mit
den mit den werken hat mir auch einen
anderen beuys gezeigt dass ich ihn
erwartet hätte also dieses
bildhauerische was sie sagen ist ein
wichtiges war ursprünglich bildhauer
zeichnungen gemacht und skulpturen und
hat dann aber zu den 60er jahren
plötzlich neue materialien auch
eingeführt ebenfalls haben sie schon
erwähnt mit dem filzhut arbeit es gibt
ein ganzes piano ein flügel den er
überzieht mit filz und fett es natürlich
auch der berühmte fed stuhl als er
schmiert fed auf einen stuhl oder in die
ecken rein das war natürlich auch ein
skandal in der damaligen zeit und den
damaligen kunstwert und 1969 gab es eine
berühmte ausstellung in der kunsthalle
bern
von harald seemann da wurden
unterschiedliche album gerade künstler
auch ausgestellt darunter boys und wir
schauen da mal kurz rein um einen
eindruck zu hören
also wir sehen hier
joseph beuys hantieren mit dem feld und
er schmiert dass da in die ritzen in die
ecken rhein und im hintergrund hört man
ein tonbandgerät das so typische absurde
langsam spies geräusche von sich gibt
wir lassen das ein bisschen alles wird
[Musik]
ja
wo ist heute dazu dann folgen
ich versuche damit etwas zu provozieren
ich suche den menschen etwas anzustoßen
vielleicht etwas was im unterbewusstsein
verankert ist
[Musik]
ja das war damals eine radikale geste
die kunsthalle bern hat gesagt stell
angenehme aus boys machen wir nicht mehr
aber das kann man heute gar nicht mehr
so nachvollziehen ich frage mich dann
natürlich können wir die bedeutung
seiner werke überhaupt noch verstehen
wenn wir sie nicht mehr
diese kraft seiner gesten überhaupt
nicht mehr erleben können das ist eine
der thesen die ich versucht habe zu
testen ist es eigentlich so wie wie
viele sagen wenn er abwesend ist können
wir das werk gar nicht mehr richtig
wahrnehmen und sind relikte von aktion
das würde ich eben nicht behaupten dass
wir die revidieren würde sagen die die
werke die funktionieren durchaus
natürlich ist es wichtig und hilfreich
die geschichten die entstehung auch
seine oder andere kommentare dazu zu
hören aber die die werke selbst also
ohne die werke selbst werden weiß nicht
da und auch nicht mehr da aber es gibt
ja diese dokumentation das video und so
weiter die tonaufnahmen und sie würden
aber sagen trotzdem muss man sagen dass
live sehen da kommt noch etwas dazu die
fettecken diese natürlich weg geht es
diesen die kunsthalle wurde mehrmals
umgebaut und das ist natürlich eine eine
aktion die jetzt festgehalten ist und
wenn wir eine fette geht gibt noch ganz
wenige der halten sind sehen sind die
tatsächlich etwas etwas trostlos der
stuhl mit fett der existiert noch
und mich hat interessiert dass das man
zum beispiel nicht genau weiß wie der
entstanden ist und im rückblick hat er
auch dank der filme der aktion habe ich
mir versucht zu rekonstruieren wie das
wie das damals gemacht wurde und
benutzte in den 60ern vor allem wer hier
sagt zum provozieren das ist ja auch
stark ein didaktisches material nämlich
die erwartungen des publikums zu
zu testen die natürlich zuletzt erwarten
dass man mit fett ein raum frau schmiert
weil eigentlich sollte man den raum ja
fettfrei halten indem man inständig
reinigen und wenn wir das jetzt hier
verfolgen was er tut das der stadt den
raum zu klären statt den zu politisieren
stadt in quasi zu abstrahieren
verschmiert und zeigt zugleich wie er
hand anlegt man könnte sagen
präparierten er imprägnierten er stellte
eine art beziehung zwischen seinen
körper und und damit auch unseren körper
und der umgebung hin und lässt uns
dadurch vielleicht auch die architektur
die umgebung den raum anders sehen also
erstellt nicht an der skulptur in einen
raum denen nicht kommentiert sondern tut
das was man eigentlich nicht tut das
museum so nicht angefasst werden
es geht gleich aufs museum los genau und
das ist immer noch auch jetzt nicht nur
angenehm sehen weil es erinnert uns an
vielleicht unbewusst frühkindliche
zeiten an schmutz an fäkalien an ein
unreines und unordnung und an vielleicht
ist ist diese unordnung dieses nicht
kontrollierbare dieses ist jetzt auch
potenziell sich infiltrieren dem
material gerade etwas was was mit der
funktion von kunst auch zu tun hat
dadurch verändert er natürlich auch
unseren blick auf den auf das was nicht
kunst ist auf den raum der eigentlich
für die ausstellung da ist und auf den
verändert unseren kunstbegriff selber
wie sie gesagt haben indem er etwas zu
kunst erklärt was gemeinhin das
gegenteil ist kurz nämlich ein stück fed
dann eigentlich die die kunsthalle bern
nach diesem film gar nicht mehr mit den
gleichen augen anschauen also das nicht
gäbe also eine spur bleibt davon zurück
ja so kann man sagen dass er die die die
kunst verändert und das lässt sich nicht
mehr wirklich rückgängig machen
das ist vielleicht auch so was wie die
frage was ist ein historischer rang in
der kunstgeschichte
jetzt gibt es neben dem feld nach den
berühmten films was hat es damit auf
sich
warum greift immer wieder zu dem
material zurück filz ist wie fett
natürlich noch einmal für einen
bildhauer damals ein unerwartetes
material
es verändert sich es kann sich denn zu
ersetzen es kann auch zu stinken beginnt
filz ist schwer ganz klar in einer form
zu halten man muss es wollen oder
fixieren damit dass die form behält das
widerspricht den gängigen vorstellungen
der skulptur aus einem dauerhaften fixen
unveränderten material
es ist interessant weil es als ganz ganz
vielen haaren zusammengesetzt ist und
natürlich ein material das alle erlebt
haben und kennen weil es auch eben erst
ein sehr günstiges und zweitens
wahnsinnig gute eigenschaften hat das
ist ein alltags material das plötzlich
in der kunst auftaucht und ein dann
fallen muss muss ich überhaupt stahl
oder glas oder andere materialien ist
eigentlich so glatt so glatt wie die
anderen materialen nicht so kalt das ist
warm weich es ist weich und wenn wenn
wir nochmal in als bildhauer betrachten
sich die große herausforderung der
skulptur ist wie kann ich den körper
darstellen menschlichen körper
repräsentieren
und er sagt es muss alternativen geben
zum soliden standbild das ist für ihn
ganz starker notiert mit der bildhauer
tradition im zweiten weltkrieg in der
diktatur wo er sagt alles vollgestellt
war mit diesen skulpturen also wie kann
ich den menschlichen körper darstellen
nicht aus eine seine starre
unveränderliche heroische figur aus ein
panzer quasi sondern wie kann ich die
die ich das getöse die eingeweide die
verwundbaren teile des körpers darstellt
von daher sind
filz und fett sicher auch elemente die
die repräsentation des des menschen in
der kunst ein stück weit neu denken
lassen
jetzt wo es wäre nicht böse wenn er
selbst nicht auch eine geschichte dazu
gehabt hätte über dieses fett und filz
und zwar erzählt ja ja einen mythos der
ist jetzt als mythos entlarvt nämlich
das als pilot sagte er glaube ich im
zweiten weltkrieg was auch schon nicht
stimmt er war bordfunker in ein flugzeug
abgestürzt ist über der krim und da
hätten ihn dann so genannte tataren
gepflegt seine wunden mit fett
eingerieben und ihn warm gehalten mit
dem mit dem filz und diese geschichte
wurde natürlich dann transportiert bis
irgendwie man dann mal darauf kam
nachgeforscht gesehen das stimmt
überhaupt nicht der ist einfach von
deutschen sucht dann gefunden worden und
in einem lazarett gepflegt worden
warum erfindet boys solche mythen über
sich selbst
der mythos steht langsam in den 70ern
und ist ende der 70er dann quasi da als
er seine große wichtigste ausstellung im
guggenheim museum in new york hat
prominente im katalog präsentiert und
beginnt natürlich auch dann diesen
prozess der polarisierung der
wahrnehmung warum warum arbeitet der
mythos
eine erklärung ist die eigene rolle im
krieg nämlich als berufssoldat
freiwillig bei der luftwaffe
also keineswegs ein opfer keineswegs in
der résistance sondern eben jemand der
am anfang feuer und flamme ist die
eigene rolle
wie kann man die überhaupt darstellen
und entscheidet sich für diesen mythos
also eine mischung aus fiktion und
fakten wo der kriegssituation des
krieges die situation kann man sagen von
deutschland im krieg war sie durch seine
biografie verknüpft wird
wenn wir den mythos quasi auf die
situation von deutschland übertragen
lesen es ist der
aufstieg des kriegers der am ende
abstürzt den krieg verliert und dem
verziehen wird also im nachkriegs in den
nachkriegsjahrzehnten wird deutschland
quasi doch den marshall plan und die
verträge wieder vom boden aufgehoben
das heißt dieser mythos verbindet und
zwar dicht wie ein filz wenn man will
all diese verschiedenen stränge und
lässt sich auch nicht völlig
entschlüsseln man kann ich sagen es ist
nicht wahr
aber wie gesagt kann man ein mythos war
also nicht wahr beschreiben das zweite
und das zweite element ist durch das
damit für filz und fett also diese
beiden irritierenden materialien so was
wie ein bedeutungs schlüssel geliefert
wird aha er arbeitet mit filz und fett
weil es ihn damals geleitet hat und das
ist eine antwort auf ein rätsel
die man natürlich mit genuss immer
wieder einsetzen kann weil damit löst
sich wenn man so will ein rätsel und ich
glaube dass diese beiden dinge führen
dazu dass der mythos die kraft hat unter
street natürlich die die ambivalenz also
kann es sein dass der bedeutendsten
deutschen künstler der gegenwart
zugleich eben als kriege freiwillig in
diesem krieg mit macht und das auch so
deklariert genau die über diese
ambivalenz widersprüche über diese
abgründe dunklen seite nach werden wir
gleich noch reden aber ich glaube dieses
dieser krieg war schon nach einem
schlüssel ereignis für ihn manche
sprechen auch von einem trauma er war
danach depressiv in den 50er jahren
würden sie auch sagen dass dieser dieses
erlebnis dramatischen auswirkungen hatte
ich kann das natürlich überhaupt nicht
beurteilen ich kritisiere aber die
rezeption die boys durch ein trauma zu
erklären versucht weil traumatisiert
waren natürlich in erster linie opfer
des krieges und die opfer des holocaust
und die nachfahren hinterbliebenen
überlebenden
und die fixierung auf das trauma von
beuys dass er als aus abgestürzt
krieger in eine depression singt und
daraus sich erneuert die finde ich eben
sehr problematisch weil sie ihn zu einer
leitfigur stilisiert und damit von den
eigentlichen opfer ablenkt und deswegen
versuche ich einen anderen zugang ich
versuche nicht die erneuerung seiner
kunst zu erklären als folge einer
depression sondern als resultat einer
konfrontation dass er die geschichte des
holocaust nämlich als er für einen
wettbewerb ein holocaust monument
entwerfen soll zum ersten mal wirklich
zur kenntnis nimmt
ja das ist interessant aber es gibt ja
auch die die gegend die gegenmeinung die
stark vertreten wird nämlich der vorwurf
an beuys nicht so zu sein dass er seine
biografie beschönigt hat gefälscht
sondern dass er eben sich zu wenig mit
seiner nazi vergangenheit auseinander
gesetzt hat also das fängt schon an 2008
aus der kunsthistoriker beatrice in
einen ewigen hitlerjungen nennt sie
haben schon gesagt beust meldete sich
freiwillig zum krieg und man hat auch
herausgefunden dass noch in den 70er
jahren sein näheres umfeld aus anfallen
fielen altnazis bestand und jemand der
diese braunen seiten an beuys stark
hervorhebt ist der boss biograf hans
peter rieger die höheren immer kurz zu
empfand in jeder phase seine existenz
deutsch
der begriff sich in jeder faser dieser
existenz als im grunde aus diesem boden
erwachsen wie er es auch selber sagte
riegel beweist in seinem buch dass sein
näheres umfeld aus den 70er jahren aus
altnazis bestand
sein persönlicher sekretär karl
fastabend mal ein ss mann der ersten
stunde
beuys hatte sich noch vor der gründung
der grünen für die aktionsgemeinschaft
unabhängiger deutscher aufstellen lassen
eine partei mit klar rechtsnationalen
gedankengut das sind viele braune
flecken in der biografie von von beuys
wie gehen sie damit um
ja das ist sehr wichtig was hans
betriebe und andere in den letzten
jahren erforscht haben dass sie geben
ein neues und differenziertes bild von
beuys und und werfen fragen auf die in
der rezeption davor verdrängt waren oder
nicht belangt worden
das heißt das bild wird dadurch
differenzierter und es führt dazu dass
wir uns noch einmal der frage stellen
ist der mythos ein mittel des aufzeigen
oder des verdrängens also wird der krieg
sozusagen oder die täterschaft wird die
wird die zur diskussion gestellt oder
wird sie quasi sublimiert und
künstlerisch verbrennt und im prinzip
sind beide antworten möglich
ich glaube es beide interpretationen
sind irgendwo legitim
es hat in den 70er tatsächlich mit kann
fasste abend zusammen zum beispiel an
der documenta 5 100 tage lang
ausgestellt
und ich habe mich eben nachdem das buch
von ihr gelesen
wie kommt er dazu hätte ja auch einen
studenten mitnehmen können
warum warum diese mensch mit einem
strengen scheitel der
völlig anders aussah ganz an beantworten
kann ich es nicht eine hypothese ist es
erstens fragt er weniger woher der kommt
was der früher gemacht hat sondern was
er jetzt macht also nicht so sehr die
vergangenheit interessiert sondern die
die jetzige tätigkeit also scheint dem
zuzutrauen dass er das nicht weiter
vertrete
das andere ist villa zeigen aber der war
ja auch bei dieser idee bei dieser
aktionsgemeinschaft unabhängiger
deutscher ja auch führen mit dabei die
klar nationalistisch auch ja die idee
ist natürlich auch es gibt ein sehr
gutes buch über die frühzeit der grünen
von silke mendes die dass die das
differenziert darstellt die au de ist
wie viele dieser grass root oder diese
früheren splitter bewegungen ein ein
sammelbecken von verschiedenen
ideologischen nuancen und der
protagonist der hat tatsächlich in der
nazizeit eine rolle gespielt wird
allerdings verlässt die partei ist nach
dem krieg in der cdu nähert sich wieder
an also es ist ein schillerndes ein
schüler das nebeneinander und hat beuys
aus taktischen gründen weil die audi
angeboten hat auch parteilose können mit
uns auf die liste mit gemacht bei euch
selber spricht von einem zwischen trick
als er will in die politik
aber er will nicht mit den etablierten
politik parteien zusammen gehen weil
gegen die ist ja bleibt quasi nur die
idee mit der ist er nach rehden einmal
auf der liste und dann kommt die
gründung der grünen als die grünen gibt
es noch gar nicht aber auch in den
grünen gehen ja die audi figuren auf
wobei es natürlich ein
auch die grüne partei umfasst ein
spektrum von rechts wo wir ehemalige
nazis haben bis bis ganz links
friedensaktivisten feministin all diese
facetten kommen zusammen und zusagen
boys ist
quasi auf ihn zu der haltung von
hausleiter weile mit den koaliert können
wir nicht oder kann ich nicht wirklich
unterschreiben weil was er in den
programmen sagt und tut widerspricht
wiederum deren haltung aber eine
koalition dass das muss man ein nein
aber es gibt natürlich danach aussagen
die riegel zitiert dass er noch in den
80er jahren preis vom deutschen genius
redet und von der auferstehung
führungskraft des deutschen volkes und
so ich glaube dass davon danach nicht
ausblenden und ein weiterer wichtiger
vorwurf von riegel ist auch das beuys
stark beeinflusst wurde durch den
umstrittenen anthroposophen rudolf
steiner den sie schon erwähnt haben auch
durch dessen esoterisches denke den
okkultismus geisterglauben und bei
steiner gibt es auch so eine
schreckliche rassen rassentheorie und
vieles habe boys sagt riegel eins zu
eins übernommen und zum teil auch das
internet die das verständnis dieser
materialien wie wie fett aus übergangs
material vom geist zur materie zum
beispiel oder auch das heißt verständnis
von tieren die wir bei uns eine wichtige
rolle spielen also die tiere aus ihr
irdisches form geistige wesen war jetzt
besser ein kruder esoteriker verstand er
sich selbst wie man ihn oft beschreibt
aus schamane in meiner leser hat nicht
aber er ist es wie ein schwamm nimmt
verschiedene ideen gebäude ideologien
aufen und transformiert sie steine ist
ganz essentiell so befasst sich ganz
früh im idsteiner liest sehr sehr viel
und ich würde auch sagen dass viele der
der ideen der formulierung der bilder
sich auf steiner zurückführen lassen
okay ich denke es greift aber zu kurz zu
sagen
das werk ist sozusagen eine illustration
von steiner weil bei steiner versucht er
selbst schon sich zu illustrieren und
und das ist auch nicht wirklich
verständlich also die die sie die
anthroposophische architektur die andere
weise kunst ist ja ein versuch die ich
zu visualisieren und boys auf das zu
reduzieren würde ja heißen dass das
quasi darin aufgeht
also es ist ein prägender einfluss aber
einer von mehreren würden sicher ich
würde sagen dass es ist wie ein gerüst
ein ein weltbild das beuys halt gibt das
ihm als orientierung dient aus dem er
dann seine kunst weiter entwickelte aber
ich kann es nicht als quasi grund von
allem was er tut sehen weil dann wäre es
ja noch einmal quasi eine dokumentation
des des steirischen kosmos aber
natürlich schwingt auch in steiners
lehre steht schwingt viel gutes zum teil
rassist ist es zum teil aus heutiger
sicht vollkommen fragwürdiges aus den
frühen zwanzigsten späten neunzehnten
mit und und dem team muss die diskussion
sich stellen dass das muss diskutiert
werden das die noch einmal auch die
frage der abstrakten kunst der
einheitssatz der kunst ist auch nicht
völlig losgelöst von rassismus und von
einem europäisch zentrierten welt
auffassung die natürlich bei steine da
ist werden wir noch mal konkret und
schauen uns den umgang mit tieren an
beister ist ja sehr interessant und sehr
früh schon da und es gibt ein werk 1965
war ein hase eine zentrale rolle
spiegelt die aktion heißt wie man dem
toten hasen die bilder erklärt
mögen sie kurz erläutern wie diese
performance ausgesehen hat das ist die
erste aus einer kommerziellen galerien
beus macht de vorher sagt ich will
eigentlich gar nichts verkaufen will
mich auf die lehre konzentrieren in der
düsseldorfer altstadt eine winzige
galerie von von chmelar und die besucher
sind an einer novembernacht eingeladen
erwarten wahrscheinlich dass es jetzt
eine rede gibt galeristen oder von einem
theoretiker und stattdessen müssen sie
draußen wurde galerie warten die
galerist kommt auch raus und im
schaufenster galerie sieht man es mit
einem goldfarbenen kopf mit einem hasen
auf dem schoß und diesem hasen erklärt
er
die galerie die ausstellung als er hat
eine preview während alle anderen
draußen warten muss der tote hat eine
preview des auf dem bild sieht man mit
der zeit dann wahrscheinlich tot aber so
ganz ganz klar ist ist es wahrscheinlich
damals auch nicht gewesen
es gibt ja filmaufnahmen wo man
beobachten kann wie wir wie er mit dem
hasen durch den raum geht die pfötchen
in die hand mit dem köpfchen auf die
bilder zeigt die die öhrchen in die
zähne klemmt als ob der hase lebendig
werde zum leben erweckt werden müssen
und die figur beust mit diesem weiß
goldenen kopf ist eindeutig lebendig ist
die skulptur sei es wäre sein ich jetzt
den roten wer erklärt wem etwas das das
ist ziemlich offen
und das schöne ist sich auch dass das
eine kommunikation mensch tier
stattfindet etwas was uns heute
angesichts der diskussion das
anthropozän sehr stark interessiert was
ist die hierarchie zwischenmenschlich
nicht menschlich lebendig nicht lebendig
all dies alles passiert da und wir
wissen bis heute nicht was er dem hasen
gesagt hat das ist diese aktion ist sehr
sehr stark aus als geste und ist ein
großes rätsel
also dann gibt es auch viele indizien
zum beispiel hat er solche fusionen und
glaube ich kupfer so oder so noch noch
an beuys und eigentlich man weiß man hat
keine ahnung wo man mit deuten anfangen
und aufhören sollte jetzt stellt sich
die frage wer bestimmt eigentlich in der
kunst bei solchen aktion was so etwas
bedeutet
selbst wenn er etwas eine erklärung
erläuterung gehabt hätte die
kunstexperten wir alle ist kunst so
offen leopard trek oder das gesagt dass
in das offene kunstwerke die jegliche
deutung zu lassen es gibt keinen
richtigen falsch wie wie gehen sie daran
dass kunsthistoriker also wie man dem
toten hasen die bilder erklärt ist für
mich natürlich wie sein ich hab's gefühl
ich bin der adressat weil das ist
eigentlich meinen beruf als
kunsthistoriker bilder zu erklären und
und ich muss mir dann auch die frage
stellen wie würde ich einen toten tier
kunst erklären also die frage wer deutet
die die wird er natürlich zur diskussion
gestellt und die die da eben der der
tote haase quasi das geheimnis ins grab
nimmt bleibt das bleibt das ungelöste
boys arbeitet vor allem in dieser zeit
das ist ja später dann anders aber in
den 60ern sehr gern mit mit rätselhaften
gehalten mit mit komplizierten titeln
deren deutung eigentlich nicht möglich
ist
da kann man sagen er wollte
unverständlich auch sein und bereits
live seien in dieser zeit ich würde
sagen ja dass es geht darum dass es
rätsel gibt die wir ich war sie als
gemeinsame frage behandeln können er
sagt mal jedes rätsel wird irgendwann
aufgelöst
aber ich glaube die die provokation ist
das dass er damit zeigt kunst ist auch
ein mittel für fragestellungen mittel
der erkenntnis zum beispiel auch
erkenntnisse über verdrängtes über
verdrängtes historisches über
psychologisch verdrängtes also es ist
ein mittel der des frage stellen und ein
mittel des gemeinsam frage stellen ich
glaube nicht dass er beansprucht all
diese lösungen zu haben wenn sonst
müsste er die kunst ja auch nicht machen
genau so ein schöner satz von beuys war
sagt kunst sei nicht dafür da dass sind
importiert wird weil sonst könnte man
auf den text abdrucken und dahin hängen
dann müsste man keine kunst machen also
es scheint irgendwie doch um dieses und
diese aktion zu gehen und diese
materialien die er wäre dass wir
betroffen werden ist diese aktion dass
man es nicht einfach erklärt bekommt was
er damit sagen will
ja es ist spielt auch der titel eine
entscheidende rolle
ich finde im unterschied zu vielen
interpreten 100 peter finde ich die die
texte von boysen nicht immer nicht immer
sehr aufschlussreich findet sich oft
sehr konfus aber die titel
die sind fast wie titel eines films oder
eines buches eingänge und die kann man
nicht weglassen also die aktion die
performance damals in düsseldorf ohne
diesen titel
die hat keinen sinn die 14 als
essentieller bestandteil titel und
aktion hängen sehr stark zusammen und es
gelingt innerhalb von von drei vier
wörtern oder einem satz etwas
aufzuwerfen
was uns auch nach 60 jahren noch
interessiert und das ist schon etwas wo
ich die die bildhauerische die
sprachliche arbeit als zusammenhängend
sehe sie haben das schon angesprochen
boys hat ja den kunstbegriff selbst in
frage gestellt und ihn versucht
auszuweiten da spricht von einem
erweiterten kunstbegriff und von
sozialer plastik und was das genau ist
das erläuterte in einem film dokument
aus dem jahr 1984 damals wurde der
zürcher sprecher harald nägeli an die
schweiz ausgeliefert wegen
sachbeschädigung weil er an hauswände
gesprüht hatte beust solidarisiert sich
mit ihm
hier sehen wir die beiden zusammen und
kräuter läutet in diesem video seien
erweitert und kunst
[Applaus]
das kann nichts moderne kunst das mich
nur sagen wer um die gesellschaft zu
verändern sahen lokal sondern nur ein
berater der kunstgriff der jeden
menschen als ein potenziell künstler
anspricht das heißt auf den kreativen
punkt kommt es an und die kreativität
als den ausgangspunkt für die
veränderung das erleben ist eine
logische folgerung denn in den raum
lassen muss ist es auch klar das geld
gar kein kapital sein kann
das kapital der gesellschaft ist die
menschen die fähigkeit dass das menschen
wollen was sie können was sie sagen wir
mal fühlen
dieser ganze reichten michigan
schöpferkraft du sagt man ist ja auch
deutsch ist das eigentliche kapital
die ideologie vom kapital war wer mag
schon nicht mehr richtig
also müssen die gesellschaft so ändern
dass sie sagen wir jenseits von
kommunistischer und kapitalistischen
ideologie etwas neues errichtet und da
ist ein gebildeter sprenger probleme da
ist ein gebildeter haar als ein kämpfer
in dieser auf die in dieser richtung
nicht das ist wichtig dass man mich
jetzt wieder kunst sagt und nein
die kunst die auch dem museum sein zählt
sondern eben dieses neue die
transformation der erweiterte gunsten
der anthropologischen die sozial kunst
die jeder tag an dem jeder auch
partizipieren ist also im infokasten
kleine kurse sich reduzieren auf maler
bildhauer musiker oder tänzer schon in
jedem beruf an jedem arbeitsplatz kann
dir
also das heißt kunst ist im wesentlichen
kreativität egal ob das im museum steht
oder nicht heißt dass dann nicht dass
jede aktion jede handlung im
öffentlichen raum oder auch sonst die
irgendwie kreativ ist wenn es platz für
transporte ist das dann kunst wo zieht
man die grenzen was hat das für folgen
jetzt ja aber man kann sagen dieses
kunst es ist wahrscheinlich nicht
sonderlich gute kunst also überschaubar
vielleicht schreibt aber wahrscheinlich
nicht aber es man kann sagen das ist
auch ein künstlicher konvention war was
ist kunst nicht kunst
das ist nicht etwas gegebenes und es
wird immer neu verhandelt vor 56 100
jahren gab es den begriff in unserem
sinne nicht über viel stärker als etwas
handwerkliches zum beispiel definiert
und da ist natürlich nicht der einzige
diese diskussion die die gilt auch für
marcel duchamp zurück die die
beschäftigt die die ganze moderne also
noch vor der künstler der ein bis
wahrgenommen hat und 1970 ins museum
gestellt hat unterschrieben also die
idee dass man auch tags gegenstände
plötzlich zur kunst erklären kann ja
dass sobald ein gegenstand im museum ist
handelt es sich um kunst weil das quasi
die konvention ist wenn sie jetzt das
papier in der konsole bern am boden
werfen dann schauen wir schon anders an
als in einem studio es ist dann eine
andere geste noch einmal es muss keine
erfolgreiche kunst sein aber das ist
ohne weiteres ist ja kein geschützter
begriff und interessant ist an diesem
filmausschnitt dass es an der grenze
spielt so die moment wo ärgerlich sich
quasi ausliefert den schweizer behörden
und dann ja ins gefängnis muss das kann
man sich heute ja fast nicht mehr nicht
mehr vorstellen dass ein zuchthaus gehen
muss das heißt es ist ein grenzübergang
und bei der definition von kunst geht es
ja auch um grenzen und umbau ist es
eigentlich jemand der permanent diese
grenzen auslotet und übertritt und
testet und verhandelt
und es ist verständlich dass wenn jemand
grenzen in betrieb das dann auch
grenzwächter kommen
das heißt die gesamte diskussion um bei
es ist auch immer wieder eine diskussion
wo türsteher grenzwächter der
kurzgeschichte des rechtsstaates der
politik jetzt hier der deutsch schweizer
grenze eigentlich fast kommen müssen so
werde von beust auch bewusst so
inszeniert und sagen hey also ihr bitte
ist die grenze zeigen mal eine papiere
und das erklärt für mich eben auch warum
die diskussion um seine rolle in krieg
in der vergangenheit so vehement ist
weil es tatsächlich diese grenzen
sichtbar macht also wo darf ich meine
vergangenheit zu einem mythos machen
also wo sind nicht was darf die kunst
überhaupt wie darf die kunst alles
erlaubt die freiheit der kunst alles
unter die diskussion die die sehen wir
permanent post riot ist ein fall also
wie viel wie viel freiheit wird der
kunst gegeben und wo ist zu viel und das
dass das können wir bei beuys sammer
immer wieder sehen und das macht ihn zu
einem stück weit
ob man nun alles oder geführt was er tat
oder nicht macht ihn aus dem spiegel
wohl das jetzt sich in der vergangenheit
reflektiert was ist die eigenen grenzen
auch zeigen indem er immer wieder daran
rührt sie haben selbst ein kunstwerk
nicht gebracht von beuys eine kiste eine
holzkiste
der titel ist glaube ich intuition warum
ist das kunst und was bedeutet dieses
stück holz ja das ist ein einmal gipfel
aus dem jahr 1968 betitelte buch heißt
ein was heißt das für vielfach das
objekt das er dann auch für den verkauf
ja also es ist ja an der
demokratisierung der kunst interessiert
und das heißt auch
demokratisierung des kunst besitzers hat
viele werke die extrem teuer verkauft
werden
er ist der teuerste künstler in europa
ende der 60er jahre bereits und hat aber
dann auch werke die jeder sich leisten
kann wie eben intuition das konnte man
für acht mark bestellen im postversand
ist ungefähr 10.000 stück davon gemacht
worden eine kleine holzkiste hat viele
selbst zusammengenagelt und tränen ist
mit bleistift geschrieben intuition und
dann sind zwei bleistiftstrich darunter
einer mit abgrenzungen versehen das wäre
vielleicht sowas wie dies das rationale
denken dass das denken den besten
kategorien und der andere spricht er
verliert sich im unendlichen also wäre
die intuition die keine grenzen kennt
und offen bleibt dann haben wir hinten
auf der rückseite die signatur des 68
also es ist autorisiert es ist zwar eben
ein stück unter unter vielen vielen
vielen tausenden aber es ist zugleich
eines das beuys in der hand gehabt haben
auf eine art ist es auch ein unikat und
und diesen mit dieser ambivalenz spielte
einen das vehikel alle können irgendwie
auch an seiner kunst als als besitzer
teilhaben und damit dann tun was was sie
wollen die die form ist ja irgendwo
zwischen skulptur und bild es gibt einen
rahmen aber es steht es braucht kein
sockel das hat ihnen das kultur
interessiert dass die skulptur vom
sockel nehmen direkt auf den boden legen
ich könnte es als als sockel verwenden
und und ich kann es auch als als form
für inhalt der verwende ich könnte
einfach etwas ablegen oder es
es starb als er mich auch
gebrauchsgegenstand und darf es auch
sein
es darf auch sein ja so für mich ist es
ein bisschen wie ein talisman jetzt es
hat ungefähr die größe meines buches und
steht wo man sie ist robust kann sind
die hand nehmen oder auch wieder weg
liegen also wie kann sie auch nicht den
ganzen tag ein können sagt wieder
weglegen
lassen sie uns noch ein bisschen über
die große dimensionen reden was wollte
eigentlich etwas hat dafür ein
gesellschaftlicher fragen wenn wir für
diesen erweiterten kunstbegriff reden
wir haben jetzt weitere aktion gesehen
es gab auch dieses zitat dass er etwas
anderes wollte etwas zwischen
kapitalismus und kommunismus
was schwebt die boys vor augen sie haben
nach diese demokratie dieses
basisdemokratische ideale erwähnt dann
gibt es ist ein rudolf steiner
also ich finde die die demokratisierung
der kunst bei ihm interessanter als das
demokratie modell das er dass er
entwickelt und propagiert aber beide
sind natürlich miteinander verbunden
also wenn die kunst auch politisch
wirken so wenn sie eigentlich immer so
er war mit der politik wie sie ist
unzufrieden und der kunst wie sie ist
unzufrieden also ist nicht so dass die
kunst in ordnung ist und die politik
nicht wie man vielleicht gerne denkt und
dann beide sind nicht in ordnung und die
kunst sorgt er sich verändern zu etwas
anderem und die politik in phasen durch
die kunst durch die kunst ja im prinzip
die die für die grenzen zwischen den
beiden aufheben und sein
gesellschaftsmodell dass er ab den
frühen 70ern entwickelt als erster
direkte demokratie also dass die
repräsentation durch die parteien
umgehen er spricht auch von einer
parteiendiktatur schritt von der
parteien diktatur das ist damals ein
schlagwort nicht nur bei ihm das ist das
ist weit verbreitet
muss auch daran denken dass das kurz
vorher kiesinger bundeskanzler ist also
ein altnazi heißt die dichter die
kontinuität der demokratischen parteien
in die zeit der nationalen die tour die
ist die ist die ist omnipräsent also
diesen mist diesen parteien misstraut er
und viele andere und entwickelt dieses
modell der direkten demokratie die nicht
wirklich funktioniert es tritt er dann
selbst auch für eine partei an
er hat beschleunigungs mittels der
grünen dar und wird dann eben gründer
mitgründer der grünen also das ist
sozusagen ohne das würden wir heute
völlig anders über besprechen wenn das
nicht wäre wäre die rezeption eine ganz
anders ist ja tatsächlich mitwirkt an
dieser partei die die heute so
erfolgreich ist und so stark das
politische leben verändert hat
würden wir möglicherweise sagen das ist
ein kunsthistorischer fall der
allmählich geschlossen ist gut es gab
auch diese aktion zb die 7000 eichen die
er an der documenta 82 pflanzen ließ
ganz castro und daneben ein passant
stein also erst waren diese 7000 steine
auf einen haufen getürmt und dann war
die idee man pflanzt 7000 eichen bäumen
und dann eben immer so ein paar laut
stein
man streitet sich auch über die deutung
es gibt auch eine anthroposophische
deutung zum beispiel greift die yacht
der kunstkritiker hanno rauterberg in
der zeit darf er sagt irgendwie man
sollte das nicht zu vorschnell als eine
grüne aktion deuten für ökologie sondern
boys spreche von einem symbol dass diese
reichen sind für eine neue
gesellschaftsordnung spricht von lehr
mit zeitmaschine und davon dass
irgendwie kosmische kräfte durch diese
steine im boden gelangen dann durch die
wurzeln zu den ersten in die ganze stadt
also wieder sehr eine esoterische
deutung
er zeigt auch wieder das ambivalente und
das unfassbare letztlich von diesen
aktionen also einerseits ist es ein werk
das im unterschied zu den 60 jahren wo
wir immer noch über die titel rätseln
sofort einleuchtet 7000 eichen
stadtverwaltung statt stadtverwaltung
das braucht keine lange erklärung
es ist zugleich unendlich komplex weil
es jahrelanges politisches engineering
beinhaltet umgang mit behörden mit
stadtplanern mit landschaftsarchitektin
sind ja nicht reichen sind ja längst
ganze fülle von von verschiedenen bäumen
die nach bestimmten kriterien an die
jeweils richtigen orte dann gepflanzt
wurden weichen nicht überall hinpassen
bürgerbeteiligung wo kommen usw
es ist ein langzeitprojekt das an der
documenta beginnt wo aber noch gar
nichts zu sehen ist außer die steine und
daneben die bürgerinnen bürger von
kassel umfasst die anthroposophische
seite des ganzen also die verbindung
basalt wo diese energie in den boden
geleitet und dann warum wieder
herauskommt ist sicher ein aspekt ich
glaube es funktioniert sowohl damit wie
auch ohne also die meisten menschen die
das werk heute besuchen wissen davon
nichts war das sehr wichtig dass das der
basalt und die wurzeln sich berührt aber
das ist dann der interessant für die
frage welche ästhetik man hat also eine
produktion stetig oder eine rezeption
ästhetik sage ich jetzt mal also wenn
jetzt diese absicht des produzenten des
künstlers in diesem fall ist war
irgendwelche esoterischen sage ich jetzt
mal anthroposophischen idee da rein zu
legen dann hat das mehr gewicht würde
ich sagen intuitiv aus irgendwelche
anderen deutungen
die haben dem vorbeigehen was beuys
damit wollte wenn wir die intention des
künstlers als das den schlüssel zum werk
nehmen ja ich würde sagen sollte man
nicht machen aus grundsteuer ist
intention des künstlers oder die
ideologien ist ein aspekt unter ganz
vielen weil wenn es ihm um die
illustration dieses steirischen modells
gegangen wäre hätte einbauen gereicht
ich würde behaupten dass das werk
niemand interessieren würde wenn es ein
einzelner baum und ein stein gewesen ist
es sind viele faktoren die zusammen
kommen und je mehr desto besser
natürlich auch der stoff ehrlicher dass
das macht ja gerade die diskussion
interessanter er muss ja auch
fundraising machen für dieses projekt
das ist es wahnsinnig teuer also einen
baum plus stein kost ungefähr 500 mark
und dass das geld ist ja nicht da sehr
geht so weit dass er whisky werbung in
japan macht also macht er nicht public
privat partnership etwas was was dann
nachher als um guten oder schlechten
wenn man will teil der der stadtplanung
werden wird jedes mittel ist die meine
ich recht um das werk zu vollenden
aber das ist ausschließlich um eine
illustration eines steirischen konzept
es geht würde ich bezweifeln weil die
dimensionen zum beispiel nicht nicht
nötig wären könnte sagen es ist ein
modell das sich im kleinen maßstab
machen könnte und dass er nicht nur
bäume pflanzen lässt unterscheidet es
natürlich von landschaftsarchitektur
weil kein landschaftsarchitekt oder
keine stadt planen wird auf die idee
kommen aus einem nahen basaltstein buch
noch jeweils eine stele zu pflanzen das
hat das hat eigentlich nicht wirklich
sinn
ich muss sagen nach diesen gegensatz
zwischen dem anorganischen und den
organischen also mit der zeit wächst
dann diese erfahrung und und der passat
stein bleibt immer gleich die reaktion
verschieben sind wirklich viele aspekte
natürlich mit mit dem boot kommen wir
noch mal zurück also wir waren jetzt
sozusagen bei diesem grünen impuls sagt
unsere gesellschaft verändern sollte
mehr nachhaltigkeit umgang mit tieren
mit mit pflanzen mit umwelt aber dann
zum thema wirtschaftssystem hatte ja
auch einiges zu sagen also einen fast
aigner eine eigene geldtheorie oder
ansätze dazu
das finde ich hochinteressant dass er
auch da stützt er sich auf auf steiners
drei gliederung modell der gesellschaft
geht aus von der idee dass es im bereich
des des des geisteslebens des des rechts
lebens und des wirtschaftslebens geben
soll
die in sich autonom sind also die
politik soll die wirtschaften nicht
kontrollieren und wiederum die
wirtschaft sondern das geistesleben
nicht kommen so erkannte man vergleicht
was die kultur oder die wissenschaften
also diese autonomie die die titel schon
ein interessantes modell das als
denkmodell dass das liegt dem zugrunde
und er stürzt sich dann auf andere soap
anthroposophische außenseiter wie
wilhelm schmid einem einem was ich sonst
völlig vergessenen theoretiker der
beiden für diese grass roots die zu den
grünen führen trotzdem eine wichtige
figur war und übernimmt von ihnen ein
stück weit eine einer geldtheorie die er
dann selbst noch mal umformuliert und
also ich kann es jetzt nicht völlig
aufschlüsseln aber was was ein leuchtet
es das sagte das geld sollte nicht
gehortet werden dem kreislauf entzogen
werden sondern es verliert quasi seine
gültigkeit es rostet wenn es nicht aus
lohn- oder als investition verwendet
wird das ist endlich ein kritik der
spekulation der finanzindustrie die die
heute selbstverständlich ist aber es
wird auf eine etwas andere art damals
formulierte und unter s damit ist er ist
ein künstler jemand der in dieses
wichtige thema der 70er nämlich die
rezession und die arbeitslosigkeit dass
wir heute vielleicht auch das etwas
vergessen weil wir die kunst dann doch
wieder aus der geschichte heraus nach
haus destillieren möchten wo er
vorschläge macht wie könnte man diese
misere begegnen
dazu auch werke macht wie die honig
pumpe am arbeitsplatz eine riesen
maschinerie wo honig zirkuliert und
zugleich permanent eine art ewiger
workshop-tag tvo über ökonomische
politische modelle diskutiert wird also
kunst und diskussion verbindet der
miteinander und und hat behauptet dass
er die antwort hat das sind vorschläge
modelle provokationen um einfach auch
von der stimme der kunst und der
qualität in dem prozess profitieren zu
können als die diskussion der ökonomie
nicht ausschließlich der politik und den
ökonomen überlassen wird
also wir sehen schon das ist unendlich
reicht dieses dieses dieses werk es gibt
auch bezug auf den kalten krieg diesem
buch stark betonen auch dieser sommer
sonne statt reagan beispielhaft voran
treiben dann könnten wir könnten lange
weiter diskutieren zum schluss
vielleicht auch die frage boys hat
ungeheuer polarisiert nicht nur damals
sondern jetzt zum 100 jährigen jubiläum
wieder die einen verehren ihn die
anderen verteufeln warum gibt es bei
diesem herrn kein dazwischen als er
selbst versucht ja eigentlich immer zu
vermitteln
er vermittelt zwischen ost und west er
vermittelt zwischen kapitalismus und
sozialismus er vermittelt zwischen der
generation der zwanziger und der jugend
als ein permanent der vermittler
vielleicht ist einfach diese position
von ihm besetzt und kann man sich nicht
mehr vermitteln interessante deuten das
nehme ich gerne als loser an vielen
herzlichen dank einer schweren gesehen
ja danke auch etwas mitdenken heute
abend gibt's noch mehr beuse darauf lust
haben um viertel vor elf zeigen wir eben
den sehr sehenswerten dokfilm zu beuys
von andreas feiert nächste woche spricht
barbara bleisch mit der
kulturwissenschaftlerin mit daniel über
die frage ob eigentlich ein weißer mann
ein gedicht einer schwarzen frau
übersetzen
darf und wie fest oder wie flüssig
dasjenige ist was wir unsere identität
nennen
jetzt geht es aber erstmal weiter mit
hunden und katzen und der frage welche
rolle diese tiere in der kunstgeschichte
spiel
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]